Vậy Anh vợ tiến trọng ra đi mãi mãi, vì trong đi vũm sử vệ trách móc không hỏi trong đã ăn uống gì chưa?
Thế lỗi dùng vụ an, chung nghe 2,5 thành sấu, ông sầm van cuy, đưa cần mấy cách có đi xửa những địt tối với chơi về.
Đến dự án cơm, bằng mệnh thịt dùng, xin năm hoàn nhìn chiến chăm sống với bài, chú tại giá trâu lọc, phân cuy hợp, tình đi ăn, gợi ít cho chồng những ông cuy bà chưa sông việc.
Anh cần sông, bà dùng phép tục cợi ít cho chồng nhiều lần những ông cuy vẫn trả lời là đang có việc chơi về.
Mình xe dụ, nhiều vợ bật điện, trách sau và giống dạc bật điện và đi giá khu vực dưỡng, thế vợ ông cuy nói nặng lời, giốt không biết quan tâm chồng, không biết hỏi đán uống gì chưa?
Bà dùng vật lại, xa này mà còn đoạn không, không biết mấy dờ dưới không?
Tức hỏi thì ông không bị ăn.
Sau đỏ giữa 2 vợ chồng tiếp tục sẽ ra cải vá, nên ông cuy đổi đánh vợ và làm bà dùng đã xuống nền cảnh dưỡng nước.
Bực tức khi bị đánh, bà dùng lứng dạy lấy con rau gần đó, hủ sỏng, ông bà đại, vào đây, dưỡng cuy sạy lời, bà tiếp tâm gì thì làm, sau đó kiến đến phía vợ.
Thế trong kiến đến sát, bà dùng đâm này 2 nhất xa và vợ vực kể nó quyết cuộc xuống, thái bệnh bà dùng thả con rau xuống dưới đến ông lấy chồng,
không hả nợ lại chồng và con trai, anh sẩm văn tê con trai bà dùng chạy ra thì thấy mẹ bị vợ khóc của nối, ông ơi, tôi lợ tay rồi, con ơi, nè lợ tay rồi, con gọi xe cấp cứu đo bổ đi,
hãy con lực tức đo ông cuy ra sân dưỡng gọi người đo đo đo đo nhận đi cấp cứu, nhưng ông cuy đã từ vàom trên đường.
Sau đó, bà dùng đến cơ quan công an đường tủ vào khai dạy nghe vợ mấy phạm tội.